you look at elon musk he talks about sex
a lot let the guy put sex memes up who
cares like i mean i feel like elon can
do basically whatever he wants right
there's no pressure but there's a bunch
of elons in the academic world there's a
bunch of ela uh
no actually sorry let me backtrack
because
the man deserves props right he's
unparalleled he's he's a ceo of major
companies you better believe there's
pressure
to behave more like a ceo as opposed to
a giggling
school boy who's posting memes
throughout the night
but that is him
and that freedom that's what freedom
looks like i talked to a lot of ceos and
a lot of them
feel like uh caged birds who have long
ago forgotten how to sing quite honestly
like they they there's like shareholders
and they come up with excuses for
themselves here's why i have to be this
way you have to understand
so on there's pr there's marketing
people there's lawyers there's all that
kind of stuff
but
the final result is the authenticity
suffocated
the beautiful weirdness of a ceo of a
leader of a creator of a scientist all
that that's all
uh
that's all gone well steve steve jobs
wouldn't have um
kept his job in uh acting the way he did
in his 20s and 30s in today's climate
but he probably would have updated his
uh
his protocols so a little bit but maybe
yeah yeah screaming at employees i mean
these are these are anecdotes right i
call them anecdata because people treat
them as data but they're they're really
just anecdotes we don't know i wasn't
there um
but you know i i like the idea of
authenticity without over-sharing
right you're very authentic but there
are aspects to your life that i'm aware
of that your audiences will never be
aware of and there are aspects of your
life that i'll never be aware of and so
you're still authentic but yeah which
wait which ones are you aware
people are gonna wonder like what what
but interesting but interesting choice
of examples um
no but i think that um
you know people lose
lose careers on the basis of
the movement of their thumbs right i
mean the chair of psychiatry at columbia
recently lost his position based on a
response to a tweet people can look that
up this is one of the most famous
psychiatry departments in the world and
he put something out there that was very
insensitive frankly and um everyone that
i
talked to about it was like gosh that
was very
very insensitive not thoughtful at all
and and he lost his job right or at
least had to step down i don't know the
specifics
you